[Music]
hello and welcome
to friendy friend of me is starring
trisha paytas and co-host ethan cloud
again my co-host
yeah he's with us every day because he's
my co-host ethan klein
it's only a matter of time before i turn
into your co-host your producer
my helper my producer ethan kline do you
think that's gonna happen
i feel like you said that's gonna happen
because you said let's make the money
williams thing happen as long as i can
be your co-host i think you think
i'm gonna be the shooting star of this
podcast i'm gonna get my own show on tv
to be honest with you i feel like we
make a good duo i think you're nothing
without me
i was nothing without you i got canceled
after eight months on my own podcast but
i feel like
but i feel like together we make a
strong power duo
i think you have the connects because
your youtube is crazy high cpms like i
get the same views as this channel
monthly and i
have like what's the length of the
videos my videos are so long
my videos are long too anyways i'm happy
to be here this is the most money i made
on youtube in 10 years
so but i was just saying like well if
you're going to go to wendy william
being the next wendy williams maybe i
want to
sit in and be a bee or yeah miss not mr
wendy williams but like
also maybe like reedus and cali major
said kelly yeah
or kathy lee she was a little better
than kelly yeah but better than them
and fatter and fatter mostly fatter
sitting on those stools
like the thai stool i would get so
exhausted like i like that i have a fat
friend to just joke about
that with i mean we could call it
something like you know fat friends
or i was thinking like uh cold tea i
just had another good tea name it was
called
your names are horrible i said we should
be like
t3 with it like it's like t like t the t
channel if you wanted to gossip so like
t3
it's good and it looks like tea so today
we did a really special
episode where we go off field to do
go yoga wait before can i just plug my
bands separate 2005
oh yeah go ahead hey guys so i have a
new emo pop punk band it's called
sad boy 2005. go to snapboard3005.com we
have band merch right now not streetwear
we're not magnamel jack over here but we
have merged sadward20005.com the album
is out on spotify itunes anywhere you
download and listen to music please
check it out it's under support 2005.
not my name tricia because it's a band
it's a collective i can't wait for you
to see these videos they're super
excited if you were into my chem
fallout boy um old school panic like
that's kind of like the sound
but like not quite there everything i do
is just not quite there
and yes 2005.com i hope i'll have a link
this time i remember how to link the
entire time
your
you're right i'll put your youtube link
like why don't you guys link trish
i'll link trish and this is the logo
where half boy half girl we're half
happy half sad it's about
being confused with gender being
confused with sad emotions so there's
are you wearing two wigs no this is
actually one how come there's like it
looks over my hair sticky
a little little comb shot a little [ __ ]
i love a little [ __ ]
my bed is crusty right now from coming
oh bro moses what is this
is it your [ __ ] i hope obviously so why
are you coming all over her bed
no it's like inside me when we fall
asleep and then it drips out overnight
are you supposed to pee before you go to
sleep because it can cause infections i
throw my like legs over to try and get
pregnant i'm like throwing my legs over
my head and hopefully it stays in there
so you guys are
so you okay you guys went from do we
want to do the goats first and then
brutal break up to trying to get
pregnant
you said you have an announcement to
make yeah you're telling me now or
should
okay exciting announcement after the
ghost stay tuned
um i don't know what it is don't wait
don't say it clickbait them
you want to watch oh you do yeah yeah
don't tell them now don't give it away
can i show you our new release that
comes out today yeah i'd love this i'm
actually a supporter of teddy frosh too
thank you very much and i'm very excited
i actually designed this one oh you did
oh so you do design some of these this
one's oh this is this is not on
instagram yet
no it hasn't been shown yet i think you
have very good looking models i asked
where all these sexy models like
they look like real models like yeah
they are they're hot
so this is the four-point hoodie and
then this is a corduroy
uh loaded shirt which is really cool you
guys got the quality at teddy fresh
one day i'm hoping to merge sad boy with
your connects
that's because it's just there's so we
work with the thing is you work with
so many manufacturers and so many pieces
it's like
there's a huge it's just a huge we can
hire a project manager
sure let's talk about it you could get a
percentage this is my i don't want a pc
or [ __ ] sad boy
it's gonna be epic we're gonna be like
the new my cam we're gonna be on hot
topic let's talk about i'll see what i
can do so this is the airbrush
you're so sweet like you are so cool to
me okay no this is dope i love this like
this is one of our
your quality is amazing thank you so
much for saying it's not fan joy
this is this is this actually i'm really
excited about these pants so corduroy
uh elastic waist pants for fatties
well you know i'm so happy because
elastic waist is like super in right now
yeah and so it's great you don't have to
worry about buttoning this is what i'm
wearing
the flame set i love this set so much i
need this set with the beanie why don't
you wear the beanie with it
i should have i realized i i should have
put it i should have worn this one
that's so dope
which one do you want we'll send you i
want the white the white and purple
i'll make sure this is i designed this
one too so you design it what do you
mean you're like sketching it
i did it i went in photoshop and i
picked the colors and i
realized exactly where the squares go
and then i pass it to the production
team and they make it like
yeah i designed this one dude it's super
cool i see tick tucker's wearing this
now bella poach wore it that's very
exciting
oh teddy fresh yeah it is so like you
know but like the production team
it's easy to draw something and be like
look i made a design but the production
team really
is who make it happen no i know because
the stuff you guys find too is like so
not you can't find it anywhere else
we make kids beanies okay i love that
why not
a new necklace lock necklace you guys
are like your own hot topic you don't
even need to be in stores
this one came out really nice polar
fleece set oh this is what i love the
sunflower this one i love can i have
this one too
sure that's so cozy kingdom hoodies
you guys should start buying more of
these because you run out of [ __ ] so
quickly like you sell out of like the
knit stuff in like a day
like just buy more yeah we're we're
trying to figure that out but
this one ela designers came out really
cool it took us a lot to
to get it right for the textures but
these are little buttons
like sewn on and it came out really cool
so that's you know that's it here i want
to ask you about something
okay i thought we're going to break the
there's one thing i want to ask you
about before we go under the goats
you made a tick tock and it looks like
you ate
a lip ring what the [ __ ] was this
so wait let me watch so the people know
so you're eating by the way you're doing
something really bizarre you're eating
muffin bottoms
i just like but i most people like the
muffin top
there's a whole seinfeld episode about
top of the muffin to you right but you
are a bottom muffin
you're a bottom muffin [ __ ] i don't
like it too sweet icing's a little too
sweet for me i just like the cake
i get a dozen just to eat by myself i
think most had two of these and i think
ate the rest of the box because i think
because i'll take the top anything do
you like you prefer top or bottom moses
i hate the whole thing he is stalking
he's a little bit weird
all right so watch this so you like the
top i should have brought you my dog
yeah bring me your muffin tops
you know there's kids in africa to eat
those muffins all right so watch this
and we edited it so you guys can see
what's going on
basically her lip ring on her left side
of her face
disappears there's a crunch and it looks
like you sw
ate it and swallowed it super weird i'm
not the only one who does this with
cupcakes and this is the greatest thing
about being an adult
i literally just eat the bottom so like
if you were to like pick
a cupcake all the bottoms
are pretty much out so it's like
it's kind of luck at the draw that's so
boring
but yeah all you do or all i do is take
this out
so keep an eye on the left the one on
the left
your right her left here it is it
disappears
and there's a crunch back it up
the ring disappears and there's a crunch
what the [ __ ] happened did you really
eat your i
really did oh my god it was so scary and
my sister's like you're gonna just poop
it out but i haven't yet
wait wait you you didn't realize that
you've swallowed it i don't chew food i
just swallow it
like i really do girl you're like you're
that's like
have you ever seen me pasta i literally
just swallowed all like a freaking snake
they start chewing
people always say that i literally don't
chew my food when no one ever taught me
no well now you might die because you
just swallowed a lippering hole
but it sounds like you crunched it how
did you not know you how did you not
know that there was a ring in your mouth
just hit my teeth i think the crunch
just hit my teeth i don't think i bit it
hey wouldn't you feel it so you
swallowed a [ __ ]
we couldn't find it anywhere like we
looked and i was like did you look
through your poop
i haven't gone yet so are you gonna look
through your poop my sister said i would
just i
feel it you'll probably i can't get over
the fact that you actually swallowed a
lip ring i know it's like an amazon one
too i'm like i hope i don't have covert
in there
probably like asbestos in it i would
disbust those
yeah well that was a bad idea i can't
believe you brought that up like so
embarrassing
[Laughter]
because i was like there's no way you
crunched and swallowed a
metal object it'd be like maybe on the
floor maybe i misunderstood but you
really swallowed that i think so
i'm not sure that is kind of as you say
everything
thank you that's icon [ __ ] really i
think so
yeah because like this is just like oh
boring video she's eating cupcakes and
then all of a sudden
super exciting how do people notice that
how do people notice these things it's
so little listen to the crunch how could
you not know this
how could you swallow that and not
notice you're chewing
like bro how is it possible to swallow a
metal it's a crunch are you sure i
didn't like hit the table i feel like
maybe i hit the table with my foot
i'm sorry i'm burpee because i just have
someone to cry but i am
i don't know i think it's in me because
i was feeling like it's
nauseous like i was feeling like a
tightness on my chest i literally felt
like it was in me i was like good
moses do you have any thoughts in this
were you there he wasn't there
he wasn't there well i was looking for
him bro that's
crazy i didn't know that was humanly
possible you are like a goat
you're like the goat that we're gonna go
greatest of all time
sure thanks all right well speaking of
ghosts
youtuber has goat merch who is that girl
that has oh erica no shade i actually
love her she's super sweet
but like i don't get it why do you have
a goat because they just they have like
a mascot and they want to
try to do something like we have a teddy
bear this ticktacker has one called ceo
of mood
ceo of mood like well shane dawson's pig
so you know you love shane and he does
that but that's like a logo he's trying
to brand where if you don't like shane
you could
wear a pig hoodie do you know what i
mean it's not like saying like
it's not like just a random thing on
there like he was like branding and
these people can't just be like
oh ceo mood dude you need merch of you
eating that
where'd the ring go trisha paytas
underneath
okay i don't know that's a good idea why
just this of you eating the cupcake and
the ring disappearing
it's awesome okay i mean and it's like
where'd the ring go
i think people are gonna buy that also i
don't want people to think i'm [ __ ]
on on youtubers that have merch they're
doing better than me like i'm just i'm
just jealous because i never had merch
and i
like you know so i'm not [ __ ] on you
guys although teddy fresh is superior
which is where i'm trying to get i'm
sitting right next to you is going up
that level
that's when i leave once i get that
connect and then i'm like you're gonna
balance out of my life once i'm a
billionaire like you guys off merch or
not merch streetwear
it's street what did mike say it's not
this isn't merch this is streetwear
yeah but it is i mean technically it's
t-shirt to streetwear
it's merged though can we watch that
video let's watch the video
because people don't know we're talking
about oh [ __ ] it
this is a mess it's fine let's do the
goat
let's do it dad could you clean this up
a little bit no
what i hate that you edit so much out
just leave it damn
okay and leave this too yeah it's all of
it yeah
okay okay let's go to the goat roll the
[ __ ] goats
we are here at the park with a laughing
frog yoga
and hello critter and we're here to do
some
goat yoga edition
it's like a romantic date no it wasn't
romantic it was kind of
like a little [ __ ] i mean i don't i
hate using that word but like there's
kids in the park yeah and you came
wearing a skirt
and it's not really appropriate but
we're gonna make i don't i don't i don't
want to say it's not [ __ ] but like
just like
permission i don't know what's the word
i don't want to know there's no word
there's no good words you can just show
whatever you want to show it's not what
you can't just show whatever you want to
show
i can just i just can't just put my dick
out for everyone to see
that's a crime but i'm very excited you
planned this this is the most any man
has done for me i'm
gonna cry um we're being covered
safe today yeah oh yeah everyone's been
tested
yadda yadda we're outside uh
cove it's fake no i'm kidding i believe
you're covered okay jake paul no i
believe
i believe everyone knows i believe very
much i didn't mean to call you [ __ ] i
feel bad i just meant like that you're
showing
you always call me [ __ ] no but i don't
mean that i didn't mean that i take that
back
you've done goat yoga before i've done
goat yoga before but these goats are
huge i'm nervous you had little baby
goats before
they were like eating your hair right
they're eating my hair i was a lot
skinnier they were a lot skinnier but
now i'm bulky i'm ready
broad shoulders the instructor said the
goats like uh
she pointed at trish and said she likes
they like big people i don't think she
pointed to me because she did
you that we're both fat and out of shape
i was like i'm not then she said they
had goats like
people with broad shoulders i mean hey
they got good taste
right should we do that again i feel
like it was too combative
no but if we're like hey guys today
we're here at go yo got hella critter
and laughing yeah but we're not doing e
news but isn't that what we're doing no
we're just doing a stupid podcast in our
own style i said it wasn't clean enough
hey guys it's
go yoga i'm ethan clyde with my co-host
tricia pedes what are we doing today
trisha today we have ghost jumping on
our back it's a new fan here in l.a it's
healthy it's good for your mental and
while we're all staying at home at
clovis
go outside wear a mask be safe and get
the mental exercise
so the people who did your goat yoga
what was the name of that place
no because trisha said the other goats
were violent and i wanted to make sure
that
they did that's not the ghost that
showed up today
the laughing goats or something it's not
the laughing go part the party goes
all those guys you don't want to [ __ ]
you got it every goat is great here in
l.a honestly
they're homegrown they're vegan they
bring you blessings if they poop or pee
on you it's good luck
all right let's do goat yoga let's face
down on your knees take a big inhale
chest up and then just start making
circles to the right
so who like why was goat yoga invented
so there was a lady doing yoga in her
barn
and she had goats and they started
jumping all over her and she decided to
make it a thing
and there's so many benefits ah there's
a goat on me
they just know to get on you huh hey
goat what why are they
they don't even need a they don't need
consent eh they just know
to do it no they'll be all up in your
business so these goats are like trained
to get on my back
yeah yeah it does feel come on with them
yeah absolutely absolutely they're
they're surprisingly agile
actually they're not as heavy as i
thought it feels kind of good which goat
is on me the big one or the little one
gigi yeah the big one
bigger one they're just they just want
to get on your back oh you're giving
them treats
i see what's going on and they're still
pretty small because they these goats
can get up to like
65
he's just just jumping on my back it
feels really good
he just gets treats they just want to
get on me for treats
we don't even hear the benefits of why
this is yeah why is this beneficial
so the number one benefit is laughter
obviously and like
okay so yeah okay um the number two
benefit i would say is like the goat
massage as you're experiencing so nice
it sounds like it's just a fun activity
it's not like a serious yoga discipline
no we want people to come and just get
in touch with their adventurous sides
and do it i feel i feel like more limber
already like i feel skinnier
they also really help with your core
strength so why don't we do a core
strength pose
all right here we go goat and just do a
couple of cat cows so
inhale exhale
forehead to pubic bone forehead to pubic
bone huh
wow that feels so good thank you gigi
see if you can balance like that with a
goat on your back come on though let's
do it i felt like i felt pretty strong
for a minute
okay here we go i got this you damn gum
would you dare do crunches
bringing your right elbow into your left
knee would i dare i would dare whoa
you guys are really good at thinking
really they're loving you you're
athletic
all right here we go maybe we're more
athletic than we there you go keep that
core tight yes
it's actually better for core
strengthening than doing this without a
goat
god loves going so do the other side
take your right leg out behind
i'm not a mountain damn that goat got me
good
oh sorry go okay there it is it's so
good
it feels good right yeah
so this in child's pose you get the
massage sometimes they catch me on the
side
man oh jesus trisha put out some pants
what the [ __ ]
is this can someone get a shot i have
sorry
someone better get a shot of that i got
shorts no i have a tampon in
oh god dude i have shorts and
tights though goats might go are they
attracted to blood
like sharks they're vegan
so one of the things we didn't talk
about were goat blessings
um as part of every class there's
usually a blessing or two
but because the goats are vegan their
blessings are good luck um and they
don't they hardly smell or anything so
like goat
poop you'll see at some point maybe um
they're like coffee beans
they poop on us they might so but they
cannot be potty trained so that's the
thing it
adds to the adventure of the class um
and then at times they will urinate but
their their
pee is basically like yellow water it
doesn't have any ammonia
i actually like a little pee holy water
i'm so impressed how flexible you are
really yeah that's crazy you're doing it
too well yeah but i'm like flexible
why why you don't look like you're
flexible i got i'm full of surprises
tricia
so you can either just keep it like this
and just keep it as a stretch and make
them about that way but if you want to
go hardcore
outside my boat i'm so fat that it's
like pressing my lungs
can't breathe in this damn boat so what
what you guys called
boat is it wait what is it oh this says
bombastic
oh mama stick which we'll do we'll do
our goat obama stand
yeah goats are really nice but like oh
he's taking yeah he's taking a dump
right there
that's goat poo that's a blessing
there's there is a goat on you tricia i
can't even feel it anymore my back is
like numb
let me know when you guys are done
okay what's in that gulp massage you
know all right so bringing your hands to
heart center sitting up
nice and tall we're going to end our
class with three bars
just to let out the stress and have a
little conversation with the goats
[Laughter]
take a big inhale and
[Music]
and again big inhale and
last one big inhale
thank you guys so much for joining us
today for
goat yoga you guys did amazing thank you
you're so sweet namaste okay so how do i
turn this
here we go engine
[ __ ] it okay all the way down and then
up is reverse up is reversed down his
drive
i think you want to reverse yeah
obviously yeah do you drive i don't even
know i don't drive i love this top
camera oh my goodness
all right it's probably pretty fast do
it it's fast but like honestly wheel is
soft and gooey
yeah and you don't have to like put much
pressure like you know force on it it's
like a smooth ride like you don't want
to drive it drives itself let's see how
much attention we get from people when
we cruise around
how do i tell if it's it's drive it's
the d it's right there you're in drive
why are you doing it some drive where
are you seeing d right there
oh my god wow the wheel's so soft dude
you know i love it
i'm gonna wave to people oh she didn't
want to say what a [ __ ] okay well look
at you
i waved tired the fact that somebody in
a rolls-royce waves hide you when you
say
and you don't wave back we are not
entitled [ __ ]
you know james corden just goes in a
circle usually they don't usually go
anywhere
yeah well [ __ ] james corden i like him i
would leave you in a heartbeat for james
corden if you offered me an assistant
yeah yeah he james corden wouldn't take
you any anywhere i think
he's too he needs the attention he's
like i'm james corden and i wear
tight gucci shirts all the time
yeah this is fun i like this car wow
this is nice this is
really nice we have more friends
everyone always says that they're like
oh they're becoming friends
it's i wonder when it's gonna fall but
there's gonna fall apart though
something's gonna happen oh
but that's like everybody in my life
that's like inevitable i just wonder
i wonder what because i wonder what what
could it do because
i don't i mean i'm pretty easygoing like
i feel like you've already tried to ruin
my life and i definitely crossed all the
lines like i don't think there's
anything i could be more insulting
and i feel like mine is just like i'm
i'm like a weapon you know with my words
and if you already handled what i've
said about you and your family like all
your family i feel like we're okay
yeah i did and i really don't you know
what i mean yeah it's all good because
like my ex i crossed the line when i
mentioned his ex-wife and i was like
she's a c-u-n-t
and then he's like okay i gotta break up
with you but just because you called his
ex-wife
yeah he was a little cuckold though he's
like um
why won't he has kids with her he
probably respects his ex-wife
baby mama and all that yeah well she's a
[ __ ]
well that's why he broke up with you
anyways we're going to keep it
light-hearted
are we going to sing at all i don't
think you could say anything that
would make me want to stop disconnect
with you but i feel like you'll
disconnect with me and like something
will happen with
moses or something you'll something
you'll find something to blame me for
for sure if we're like done done i don't
i think it'll be awkward for me it'd be
inappropriate for me to continue on with
his family
why it just sounds bad look at the
capulets and the montagues
they both ended up dead you and me are
gonna [ __ ] die in the same tune
together not like gangsters and
well we're not in love let's make that
very clear too people think we are
people think you're kind of into me
people don't think that they definitely
do on your elastic back everyone's like
where's trisha ethan's into trisha i saw
the comments what yeah
they were saying that we're friends and
siblings i suck
look at the last one he did with elo
they're like he's so introduced the last
one i did with eva yeah on your tic tac
i read the comments swear in my life i
read them i can find them they're the
top comments
read one to me that with any amount of
likes that says i like you
i'm sure it's the first one because i
literally like you know i like it's not
uh it's not the first one definitely
it's not the first one it's probably top
five
ten go ahead okay i'm finding it right
now i'm finding it okay
do you think that i am interested in you
even first the top one is it makes you
friends with trisha which i don't even
get the joke
um he says no [ __ ] makes you friends
with trisha that's
that's why i go right here okay but that
doesn't mean i'm interested in you
no there is one there is one okay so you
found one in a sea of like thousands of
comments and you're
why are you obsessing over the fact i
want him and tricia together how many
likes does it have
how many likes well you can't see like
contact there's no likes
oh i swear on my life i did not know
that so three likes
i'm pulling over what is happening you
didn't know there was on tick tock
god ethan likes trisha three likes look
at that ethan likes
trisha you didn't know ethan likes
trisha three likes
and that's your type of comments no
that's not nobody likes you
it says you are friends with trisha and
that's the most
liked yeah it's not to do ethan likes
trisha
what do you think that i like you do
yeah like sexually
no i think you have like a crush on me
you really do
yeah i think you have a little bit i
mean i know like it's like
you have a sickness crushes on people i
feel like you know
i i promise you a little bit it's fine
it's healthy to have a crush on people
it's fine it's not a big deal
because you wanted to move it to twice a
week yeah
because it's good not because i want to
[ __ ] you i mean
no i think you have a i think you have
an illness that you think
well everything has to become sexual
with you and you think every guy wants
to [ __ ] you
i guarantee trisha i mean with peace and
love i really would rather [ __ ]
put my dick in it in a socket that's
what most guys say like you know like
insults say that too
you know what i mean i feel like most
guys say that but hey i'm not i'm not an
intel i have a kid
i figured out i don't think you have
that much i have
a child that's proved that i've had sex
at least one time yeah making me not an
insult
probably checkmate i don't even know
what it taught me
it means that they're and it means that
they don't have sex but it's not their
decision
right really that's what an insult is
just they want to have sex but they
can't
get any because life isn't fair and
women hate good guys
honestly they shouldn't meet me i'd have
sex with anybody i'd be like okay
like trish is the antidote to end seldom
and death don't even have sex with me
though
i don't know how to convince you that i
don't want to [ __ ] you um i think it's a
crash i don't think it's you want to
[ __ ] me
how do i what does a crush mean that i'm
attracted i'm not i'm not
it's pure friendship
well i'm getting the feeling that you
maybe want to [ __ ] me no
no like no but i feel like every like
there's not
yeah how do i prove to you that i have
no
there's no crush how do i prove to you
you can't it's just in my head forever
um that's cool though are we gonna say
are we not singing this time or not
you're over it
no let's sing okay i may not live
to see a glory to see our glory
oh people are just i will gladly join
the fight
and i will gladly join this is horrible
i hate it
look at the giant dreidel trisha you
can't just scream jew
you can't just drive around screaming
why is that soupy
take dreidel
a dreidel do you know the dreidel song
yeah you want to sing it
oh i made it out of clay and when it's
dry and ready
why did i i did not know you knew
hamilton like when you said that i was
like
wait really i know it why have you never
said that before i literally have so you
just don't listen to me
you've never been like oh hamilton's
cool like i i i
listen i'm a hamilton fan i told you
that you just now all you think about is
that
i want to [ __ ] you which is weird
because there's other things going on
but should we do that hamilton song
where he's like trying to [ __ ] her
which one is that the one that's like
she led me to her bed
her face turned red she led me to her
bed and said i can't say no to this
i love that song wait wait
nothing like summer in the city
and someone looking pretty
ryan reynolds came into my life she said
[Laughter]
you're not don't put like don't do that
be immediate miss cheating me
suddenly he's a pentagon jokes about
us having we're acting it's not acting
we're in a car
[ __ ] spitting we've definitely all
got covered if any of us have it i don't
have go but i just got tested like i
literally get tested all the time
you say our love is draining and you
can't
go on
i think you low-key want to be on
broadway would you do it
no really no why you're too scared
why the [ __ ] would i go on broadway
because you're good and you like
performing he played your music for me
last time
i mean not broadway good i think i'm
broadway good
yeah that's kind of good although you're
like not the best driver i'm not gonna
lie what what am i doing wrong i'm
literally you're
very heavy-footed with like slamming it
like on the brakes like you don't slow
down you do like a break you do like a
dan do you have do you agree i haven't
really noticed yeah
really oh i'm like a little nausea but
i'm good oh my god
domestic life was never quite my
little does he know that his daughters
peggy angelica eliza sneak into the city
just to watch all the guys at work
angelica work work elijah
and peggy the skyler sister
peggy do you want to sing some of your
music yeah can i play it it's
royalty-free
it won't get flagged yeah play it oh my
god really oh thanks for letting me
promo can we actually put this in the oh
we have so many things put in the
description
probably cut like a lot of that so can
we put all of it on i'll put on my
channel the whole thing
why it's so good oh my god whatever you
want with it but let's can you give me
all of it
all right you ready this is my new song
sabor 2005 is my band
i really like the cover art thank you
it's very newfound glory
oh you're a pretty good singer trisha
thanks three or
at least in that voice we go oh i'm
lower i'm like an altar i'm alone you go
lower the wrong
side i'm all fallen like wait let me go
to my favorite part
all right feels like two thousands kind
of music
it's called sad for 2005. oh yeah i love
this song
don't tell me that i'm all right
i can't see your name but i don't want
to scream
i wish i had a time machine i heard this
one on youtube let me hear you crank
this one up
wait this one already played
it's a family affair it's you guys this
is about moses this is the one it's a
family affair oh that's about me
yes oh [ __ ] because it's a family affair
all right i didn't gonna
even sleep at night from your eyes
like you'll be happy when i'm dead
because can you imagine that front of
these episodes the day after i die like
you're gonna get all the views
yeah that would be a banger but that
would be a bigger thought
but i will get have way more banger
episodes with you alive how do i park
this [ __ ] here we go
i don't think so because you're the last
one that was nice to me in this life
so so you think that it would just be a
tilde banger if you died yeah
it'd be worth it you haven't died you'd
get so many views but like wouldn't i
get more views you being alive i don't
think so
i'm gonna be more popular when i'm dead
which is honestly why i'm not scared of
death i'm gonna be like blowing up when
i'm dead like i'll be on merge and hot
topic and stuff
i wouldn't bank on that i guarantee i'm
going to be that person
i don't i'm not sure i'll be like in
elvis at 42
kilo over on the toilet okay we are back
first of all lots to talk about great
singing
we did some singing i was so impressed
you were you knew like all the words
i'm a hamilton super fan i tried to tell
you that about it like why weren't we at
passover
or where were we at rosh hashanah why
were we not watching hamilton on disney
plus
i didn't occur to me i mean you guys
have like the news on you're looking at
james charles twitter
like we could've been watching him with
him okay well i i am a fan of hamilton
you know the problem with hamilton is
that ela
i love it but every time i play it
because i've played it so much eli gets
mad
oh yeah she hates it just because i
listen to it so much in a polisher so i
kind of like facing it out of my
my my repertoire of music she's an
immigrant she should love that it's all
about immigrants
i don't think she hates the message i
just think she's tired of listening to
the same music over foreigners too
in general because my dancers i took
them to see that a lot of foreigners
don't understand it because it's like
it's hard to understand if you're an
english speaker
so like if you're not a native english
speaker it's like hard to understand
like my mom doesn't understand it you
know what i mean like she's like i don't
get it
so much words and it is it takes a few
times to digest like my french friend
who's been here like ten years is like i
don't know what's going on i can't
understand anything that's happening
yeah they talk fast yeah maybe like it's
was super embarrassing and i hope that
dan
edits a lot of it out because we were
driving for a while i loved it that was
so much fun
your car is so baller yeah thanks i want
it thanks in front of me i was able to
get it that was my purchase half a
million dollar car
yeah six that oh dude the rent so i
don't i want that car but
it costs six thousand dollars a month to
lease and so i'm not i can't do it i
just can't yeah you got a kid
no you can you might have the money yeah
but like it's you feel like a [ __ ]
idiot
i think it's more like a comfort like
your life is stressful right like my
life i have a lot of anxiety so it's
like the nice comforting thing i don't
have to get my car and have anxiety
and it does i mean if you can afford it
obviously but like for me it's like that
splurge like i've always forged on cars
first class like those are two in breaks
those are like three things i've always
worked on even though i was pulling
clothing i don't know i like fashion
nova i'm like so cheap
oh 70 000 back yeah the purse is for
sure always but
so um so the singing was good the goats
are great dan said that trisha was a
better singer i asked him though so you
guys let me know in the comments who
belted it better you weren't trying i
feel like if you actually tried it would
you
i mean i live to see our glory
that's not you trying so you're being
funny but you're better pitched than me
i've really bad pitch i
don't know what pitches dan who has a
better pitch i don't know pitches
what is pitch i'm not really sure either
i just know i'm never on you just know
it's bad
so anyway the singing was fun the what'd
you think of the goat yoga
that was so good but can i say like
people are like of course she is i'm
getting insecure around thin women
i feel i felt a little intimidating so
skinny and i was like the instructor the
goat lady the answer
all of it all of it any girls like you
know what you told me that was super
funny
the reason that you like the rolls-royce
is because it's so big it makes you feel
small
it's true because i used to have like a
lamborghini and i felt like a big fat
ass getting out of that all the time i
was like i just like squeezing in like i
just looked horrible
this one i'm like oh i'm so tired i was
like oh that makes so much sense now why
you love it because it's huge it's like
a boat
yeah if you see my mukbangs i put my
chair all the way back so i'm really far
from the camera so i look so tiny and my
car is so big
that's very funny i love that i looked
huge remember the first one of me and
moses we were in a porsche mcconnel it
was so tiny
and i looked three thousand pounds moses
looked 100 pounds i was like oh my god
it's all about the on camera perception
of chorus
oh so it's kind of a prop if you think
about it it's yeah the write off for
them
so i got to start doing car moving so i
go right off
my [ __ ] 500 000 car listen to the irs
listen it makes me look
small it's part of your business yeah
it's part of my business
it's a total write-off acceptable to the
world and people like skinnier people
let's just face it people are nicer
seeing your people
but it was let's just face it so go yoga
the thing is like
okay so i at least found out that it's
just a gag it's not that serious
what do you mean what do you think it
was serious how serious well because you
know you hear goat yoga and you think of
all these people like doing serious yoga
with goats and you're just like why are
people doing yoga with goats
at all i don't think that was it i think
it's literally for instagram and stupid
just for fun okay yeah yeah i'm glad i
understood i felt i
feel like i worked out though i was like
my heart was actually like as kind of
short of breath
you know we were shooting a tick tock
last week and i got a little worried
because you got so
winded we like jogged like only five
okay but that's because my boobs when
i'm bouncing
oh i'm getting winded i was like [ __ ]
i'm out of shape with damn
no you're not out of shape you're very
strong um yeah i definitely have been
out of shape i used to be in really good
shape but
i'm just yeah i've been exercising like
a year
so the goat yoga was good i would be
wary i just want to follow up on
something we were talking about during
the goat yoga
is that the party goats i don't know if
you don't met they said not to mention
this
you love just pissing people off like
you'll never get to work with hello
critter again
[ __ ] not hello critter they have bunnies
wait hold on i just want to say because
it's like a psa that the
that the she was like these are violent
the party goats are violent and when the
party goes show up
people leave she definitely did not i'm
just saying if you guys go somewhere in
the party goats show up you should
leave because they're violent and they
eat not violent that's what she said she
was like listen the party girls they had
party goats on me and they were fine you
said they were eating your hair you chew
on your hair a little bit so that's all
i'm saying these one pooped and the
party goes did not poop on me
well okay i'd rather get pooped on than
attacked and violently
if they don't attack you they chew your
hair that's not talking i'm just saying
i'm just giving a disclaimer about the
party goats if in case anybody wants to
go out there i feel like i look like
anthony padilla
in 2006 right so uh let's talk about
the podcast so um you want to talk about
moses everyone's wondering what's going
on with you
is everybody wondering are you asking no
one asks no literally dude
all the comments were like how are you
guys not going to talk about what
happened when when did they ask
the last episode we had so much to go
over that episode though exactly so i
and you guys were still kind of working
it out so don't talk about it here i
felt like
it's not right to talk about someone
when they're not here you know what i
mean okay so let me ask you some
questions
you guys broke up a few weeks ago and
now you're talking about um
i would say we took a break having
babies did you upload a video saying
we're getting pregnant i mean what the
[ __ ] yeah i wouldn't say we broke up i
want to call it a breakup you had a
break
we had a break like it was a good now
you want to have kids
we've been wanting to have kids it's not
like a new like i mean we're both like
that age and
so do you have what was the announcement
because i actually don't know what it is
oh
this is so exciting we officially
it's done signed we signed last night we
bought a house
are you [ __ ] kidding me you guys did
that yeah we got it last night
well congratulations but holy [ __ ] yeah
so you guys are you guys bought the
house you were telling me about yeah and
our names are on it do you want to
oh my god i can't believe you guys got
that house
i mean congratulations thank you like we
got it for such a good price that in my
head this is a gated community
it's gated and gated inside the gate oh
it's gated gated yeah
oh dude i love the gated gated and then
you know we got
moses security over here ex-israeli like
army like he's like all tough and [ __ ]
he's gonna throw your ass to the
[ __ ] wolves if somebody comes yeah no
no he's so
he's gonna push you and run he's about
to [ __ ] you i'm out that's so not
george costanza style like the haunted
man no he's super protective and um
yeah in my head i thought okay when we
were on our break right i'm like okay so
wait whoa whoa
you guys just made this huge commitment
to each other you bought
you co-bought a house both your names
are on the deed yeah
and half and halfway but you guys almost
broke up he's the first guy that ever
would i could even have this
you guys split the 50 50 he put just as
much way to go moses
right i'm so proud of him like i told
you did you need a loan for the down
payment
no oh my goodness moses good job dude
moses can i just say i was totally when
i first met him i totally judged him i'm
like oh my god you live in like a shitty
water museum
right here but he had no other space he
like lived there so i was like okay why
are you like living there
but yeah owning it doley i was like oh i
love this guy already good credit all
that stuff but then i was like oh you
like he didn't even have like
a real shower it was like a supportive
potty shower and i'm like what's up
and it was con ghetto and then i was
like judging him but this is what i'm
saying ladies never judge someone based
on where they live because
yeah but he owns the property and also
his bank account was fed as [ __ ] i was
like oh damn okay
so honestly like i like having someone
equal but aren't you guys a little bit
worried about how rocky
relationships well listen here was my
here's my way because we did a break
right
and we were in the process of like
seeing if we're gonna get this house or
whatever we got this house for
such a good price like they didn't even
counter offer us
and so we're like yeah cause and we're
like and so i was thinking
okay if we get below asking did you get
like percentage-wise
how much percentage why is baby
oh wow so i was like okay if you said
three hundred thousand yeah three
thousand dollars
so in my head i said okay when we're on
this break i'm like you know what
counter
huh dating a little right like 25 000 or
something
75 000. um so a little bit but nothing
and so basically i was like in my head i
was like
if we get the house we're meant to be
together if we don't i'm just going to
go separate ways
so it's like a did you on your head ever
like you're like okay if this happened
yeah but yeah but you have to know that
that's not
that's not really how the world works
i've just never been in like
neither one of us has been in like a
long-term relationship but
it's like for me i never lived with
someone he never lived with someone and
like this is like and we're both we're
old
we're both like [ __ ] old so it's like
hey look if you guys break up you sell
the house and you split the
or i take it and pay him the money oh
yeah you can pay in equity
he said when we sold the house we knew
well honestly when we saw it it was like
it's so perfect the way it's like laid
out and stuff like that so
eight thousand square feet it's huge and
the actual house i mean it's
bougie now bigger than my house is it
yeah well you guys are in this like
fancy ass neighborhood we're kind of
further off of l.a
you're in a gate in the gate true yeah
we got the double gate
um i want to get in the gate in the gate
i want to move into your community in
the third gate
you should move into our community
heather locklear lives there bret
michaels
um but anyways um would you be mad if i
moved into a gate in a gate in the gate
you can't fight me okay i'm gonna build
my own gated community in your gated
community
i mean that'd be dope if you guys live
near us that'd be cool we'd like you're
too far i know where you live it's too
far away
well yeah it's really far yeah
but we're next to like our friends like
we have friends so like oh
i mean i love the area you guys moved to
but it's really nice so
um yeah so we got that last night and i
was like well congrats holy [ __ ]
and it's just like yeah did she fart
no no no we both know that's so gross
like that's that's like
our she doesn't rip ass in front of you
gnarly because you're mukbang and you
get all this crazy food you must be
ripping ass somewhere
i don't i don't i really don't you know
i don't even go to the bathroom like i
can't even go to the bathroom like i
don't go
you something passed the [ __ ] lip
ring out
there's a lip ring somewhere inside of
you yeah why am i period now so
whatever yeah you know trisha was on her
period and
like the goats were sniffing their [ __ ]
they were getting into it
was the sky i imagine the goat because
they'd like eat everything like eating
your used tampon
i don't know why that image in my head
is horrifying at the beginning our
relationship moses said he would never
have sex without my period and now he
assists me in my period so i feel like
he's really in love with me gross
he said he like smelled the blood just
from like being next to a girl one time
i'm like okay that's so dramatic i got
so pissed him for that look that's not
real
you can't smell it why not yeah
so like that's why i know we get along
because
he scooped a sponge out of me one time
when i was bloody oh god
like a vag sponge no like a makeup
sponge you put up there when you have
if you want to have sex on your period
and it was too far up there mm-hmm
you put a [ __ ] sponge in your fashion
yeah it's desperate it stops it like
absorbs it but then to get it out you
like hook it out let me just put a towel
down or something
oh that's too messy i don't like that i
don't like differently
so you scooped a bloody sponge out of
her yeah
and i had no problem with it yeah it was
crazy because at the beginning he's like
i hate how deep was it
as deep as you can imagine yeah how deep
in were you like wrist
it was so hard to get out we're how deep
like
he has skinny fingers how old were you
the whole hand not like
fingers so you're gonna talk about this
but not the dildos you're like i'll talk
about scooping out of
no i could that he didn't want to talk
about the delta i'm happy to talk about
anything
are you gonna come to our wedding of
course why wouldn't i
he told me i don't know if it was like
kind of like a proposal but half-assed
but he's like he goes well we have the
house so of course we're going to get
married now i'm like well
is that a proposal or like what because
he can't he keeps saying that stuff to
me he's like
well we're going to be married i was
like i don't get why i think he's
i think if i had to guess he's testing
the water
oh like you think someone say no could
you imagine that'd be like the shock you
really
want to make sure the girl says yes if
you know what you're doing
don't take her to like a dodgers dodger
game and propose on the field and then
you know like these [ __ ] she says no
it's like bro
i just want you to know my intentions
his intention is to marry you
oh wow that's what he's saying right now
well maybe a potus my sister so she can
come to the wedding
i will i think you have some work to do
would you come to the wedding
i said yes of course why would i not
come to the wedding i don't know if we
could invite you because i think we're
having a small
like affair my brother-in-law and
my friend don't invite me could you
imagine i mean i'll be like all right
[ __ ] it i don't i don't need to leave
the house
i'd be surprised i'd be a little i'd be
offended yeah
but i wouldn't be like i depend how
small is it
are you gonna invite like other people
you know from youtube
like shane oh well that's my best man
like that's my best man
so so why the [ __ ] shane get it invited
my best friend what about my
what about his sister he says he's not
close with you guys his word's not mine
oh my god that's obviously well i'm
gonna stop being madness right now
i like that anyways everyone are invited
dan and his girlfriend are invited you
not so much well so yeah that would
confuse me yeah
dan's girlfriend's like only fans can
get only bands
yeah anyways well we're good so big
announcement
we're good we're happy we've all
apologized
do you accept my apology always yes
thank you
and and moses was working on to make
things right they bought a house so
apparently that means you'll
forgive him moses is like so handsome
smart
funny like has a good job sucks only
negative bad tick ducks
horrible dick dogs the only thing worse
might be is youtube videos
oh my god does that offend you moses
no at least what
oh even even if you say it's bad moses
has a horrible channel channel water
check it out no but he like no it's fine
we love it it's fine it's all good
honestly if it makes them happy like so
does your family know that you guys
bought a house together
yeah we told them so what was their
reaction
they were happy you know what they're
happy if i'm happy i still think he owes
an apology like you know
like
yeah but i shouldn't have to like tell
him to apologize like that should be a
no-brainer right away but anyways it
doesn't matter
um but yeah i mean are you gonna call
her today
yeah he said yes you can't push them i'm
trying to get things moving
yeah it's in the works you got to hype
yourself up think about what you want to
say that's a tough phone call
yeah well i mean like i said they know
we have a house together and like
they're they're
like easy going people is it a new house
it's renovated they redid it they bought
it like 2018 and flipped it it's
it's so beautiful big and perfect and
moses does furniture so we're going to
like customize everything
i'm so excited like the whole house
we've already planned out it's like
really exciting
um so i'm excited about that and i don't
have to pay his fee anymore like at the
beginning when i first met him he told
me he would give me a friends and family
discount
it's like you're not going to go to work
i mean but were having sex and you're
like you're still going to charge me for
the well hold on hold on hold up
that's like oh you [ __ ] wait i i don't
know if this is a good analogy but if
you're [ __ ] a drug dealer do you get
the drugs
okay so maybe maybe she has a point yeah
maybe she has a point
i was like where's my furniture hookup
and he was gonna still charge me like a
fee i was like what the [ __ ]
are you gonna charge her a fee on top of
the cost of doing
business labor that's pretty high that's
a hustle yeah that is a hustle a little
bit
like what i mean she's [ __ ] you
should be grateful every day
i mean damn eating i was doing postmates
all the time you know
i mean you think so good you know what
guys i've never paid for a date when we
go out he always pays
no well that's yeah that's good but
still yeah he always does he's really
good that way
and he charges us obviously he should
you guys are not close you're like not
even fam
so annoying why do you keep saying that
say one sorry you keep trying to
trivialize all of his relationships
he's not that close to you guys i don't
think maybe you need to fix that not me
well he's denying it he's saying you're
like who said that when i said did you
tell me because we don't talk like that
i was alright
you want to talk about it in the video
no that's not what you said moses oh my
god i hate this that's not what he said
but that's why whatever i think you are
perverting the truth
mm-hmm if i have to be honest what's
perverting no i swear oh my god this is
so
you don't know perverting us you of all
people i don't know perverting but he's
literally just he literally said i
wouldn't make that up that's such a
random thing to make up but
you know that you know he's not close he
leaves all the time he doesn't stick
around like he's not here to stay
he comes and pieces out okay don't worry
she's not gonna drive a wedge between us
if it was up to you he wouldn't have
anybody in his life but you you didn't
even say happy birthday he doesn't have
anyone else i did
you didn't have birthdays did you
yes you didn't say a birthday to him
moses is giving us the kibosh
everyone's doing this to the room i do
have a hanukkah gift but it's more for
the set and not necessarily for you
well hold on let's do a gift exchange no
but i already got my gift and it's for
the set and not for you well what the
[ __ ] i want a gift
where's my rolls-royce you're rich you
want to do a gift oh [ __ ] all right
you're gonna buy me a rolls royce [ __ ]
what am i i buy okay fine let's do a
gift exchange well hold on we should put
a money cap because i don't want to go
oh no i don't do this [ __ ] do you know i
ruin like vloggers parties all the time
because they like 50
presents and i always come with like a
thousand dollar ipad
okay but how much are you going to spend
because i need to know what's the
ballpark like what you're thinking
because i'll buy you like a birkin a
birkin
no no no no [ __ ] no rolex no
okay can i ask um ela what you would
like because i want to buy something you
want
yeah you can so okay okay like i want to
buy something let's do a gift exchange
on i love giving in december i don't
know when's the closest episode but
we'll know monica's next week hanukkah
episodes next week it starts the eighth
it is yeah i have a little hanukkah
outfit planned oh [ __ ] so
i guess it's going to come as the grinch
but i'll save that for you i'm coming as
the grinch
no you're going to be the little girl oh
you're going to be the little girl
because you always want to be the
[ __ ] girl
bro stop now i know you're a liar we
literally talk
female grinch i am sexy zoom in
talk tell that she's a liar that's the
episode you said you were gonna be cindy
yeah i did change my mind though okay
the grinch is until the 21st we have
hanukkah next week another week in
between and then the grinch
i'm sexy grinch
is that it alright thank you for
watching sadboy2005.com
check it out coming for your brand teddy
fish
you